Let's look at the solution
to our block size quiz.
We have a 32 kilobyte cache,
with 64 byte block size.
And the program that
accesses N variables,
that have lots of temporal locality.
Meaning each of these variables is
accessed often in the program, but
no spatial locality, meaning they're
nowhere close to each other.
The question is what is the largest N,
the number of these variables,
that still results in a high hit rate?
Now X1, when we bring it into the cache,
we will bring an entire
block worth of stuff around it, and
because there is no spatial locality,
that means that none of the other
variables will be in that block.
When we access X2, same thing,
we will bring 64 bytes worth of stuff
that doesn't include any
of the other variables.
So every time we access
one of these variables,
we will need 64 bytes worth
of space in the cache.
If we want to have a high hit rate,
because these variables have lots of
temporal locality, we want all
of them to remain in the cache.
That is,
we want all of them to fit in the cache.
So the largest N that still results
in a high hit rate Is how many
blocks can we fit in our cache, really?
It's a 32 kB cache,
there are 64 byte blocks,
how many blocks do we have,
so the answer is 32 kB
divided by 64 bytes, which gives us 512.
So the answer here is 512.
If we have 512, or fewer variables,
then the fact that each one of them
has its own cache block in the cache,
although the variable is probably only 4
bytes in size, is not going to hurt us
in terms of hit rate, but
if we have more than 512 variables.
Then even though there is
plenty of space in the cache,
if it's four byte variables,
512 variables is two kilobytes worth
of actual stuff that we are using.
The block is much larger than that, but
because we are fetching an entire
block when we have a miss.
We will not have a good hit rate if we
have more than 512 of these variables.
In order to be able to have more
variables than this, we really need them
to be close to each other, so that we
can benefit from spacial locality.
Meaning that a block we fetch for
one variable needs to include
some of the other variables.